I do have some very unfortunate news to
tell you what
um she didn't make it this is the moment
police officers told Alec Baldwin that
Helena Hutchins had died now
investigators have determined that he is
responsible and will charge the
Hollywood veteran with involuntary
manslaughter saying nobody is above the
law he was actually the producer on this
film he was present on scene he's an
actor who's probably starred in 40 plus
gun movies and he said I believe in
reports and interviews that he's very
familiar with the use of guns Helena
Hutchins was 42 years old a rising star
behind to the camera she was recording a
rehearsal inside this church set in New
Mexico when Alec Baldwin shot her dead
last I got from her was it went in
through her right and out the left back
okay he's always denied pulling the
trigger but investigators have pieced
together what happened and say he did
yes sir all right
Baldwin has returned to normal life
since the shooting regularly appearing
on the red carpet with wife Hilaria in a
statement a lawyer for the actor said
this decision distorts Helena hutchin's
tragic death and represents a terrible
miscarriage of Justice Mr Baldwin had no
reason to believe there was a live
bullet in the gun or anywhere on the
movie Set he relied on the professionals
with whom he worked who assured him the
gun did not have live rounds we will
fight these charges and we will win
over the past year and a half I've
spoken to several people who worked on
the film rust some of whom raised
concerns about safety in the days before
Helena Hutchins was killed one described
guns lying around in the sand another
described what they called a willful
disregard for the welfare of caste and
crew one of her close friends telling me
this week he was praying for criminal
accountability for her death
what is your full name
[Music]
the armor on the set Hannah Gutierrez
read was in charge of weapons despite
being just 24 years old at the time
she's also been charged with involuntary
manslaughter
assistant director Dave Halls here in
the blue shirt made a plea deal
admitting there was sufficient evidence
to convict him of negligent use of a
deadly weapon
Helena Hutchins left behind a
nine-year-old son her family welcomed
the charges prosecutors say if Baldwin
or others had done their job properly
she would still be here Martha Kellner
Sky News Los Angeles